holy moly this is some strong flavored
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
hi i'm piano i'm a producer for tasty
and today i'm going to be making a very
old recipe for ice cream this recipe was
made by a woman named lady anne fanshawe
in the 17th century i'm going to try out
this recipe just to see what it was like
to have ice cream in the 17th century so
that means no refrigeration just making
it on ice i expect this to be a little
weird
i do have two of the flavorings that she
did mention her recipe one is blade of
mace these little bits are the ones that
surround the seed that we know to be
nutmeg and then orange flower water now
this seems like one that i could go to a
very fancy ice cream shop and they would
probably use today
[Music]
it smells like aromatherapy first i'm
gonna make the ice cream that calls for
a blade of mace here are my three pints
of cream i'm gonna heat it probably she
doesn't say how hot with a blade she
calls for a singular blade
one doesn't seem like enough
pinch gonna mix them in there okay my
moccasins are gonna get hot i'm starting
to see the fat separate so i'm gonna add
in my sugar but it doesn't say with how
much don't want it too sweet and maybe
i'll go a half a cup at a time because
you can put it in but you can't take it
out
[Music]
let's go one more oh wow this is really
taking on some color now
i'm not really getting the blade of mace
at all but i feel like back in the day
people weren't just like dumping out
loads of spices because spices are quite
still are but used to be quite expensive
so i'm gonna turn off the heat and let
it steep for a little bit kind of like
tea
it's there you know at first it's like
sugar milk and then as it lingers on you
get like a little christmas effect i
just have to chill this bad boy so i'll
strain it as i pour when i wrap this
very very very well because i will cover
it in ice
she calls for just covering the
container with ice but we know that you
need a little bit of salt to keep the
ice extra extra cold for this to work so
i'm going to add some salt to my ice
bath in order to ensure this actually
freezes just going to pop this in there
[Music]
sprinkle on a little bit more salt
this is not going to work it feels cold
but
it's just
sitting there the main difference i'm
for seeing is that blade of mace it's
steep to develop flavor over time where
with this one as much as i put in is
probably
what it's going to taste like so i'm
pretty much going to go let's say a
teaspoon i'm almost going to treat it
like it's vanilla extract because i have
tried vanilla extract on its own and it
is not delicious
tastes like sugar milk let me take a
little taste of this just to see like so
i know what i'm working with
[Music]
oh ah
it tastes like i drink a bar of soap i
don't even know how much of that flavor
i want to get in there that really
overpowered my mouth i can't not taste
it right now let me give it one more
taste
[Music]
just a touch more i'm definitely
proceeding with caution can you please
try this let me know
do you taste it it's mostly cream okay
well thank you
time to add more orange flour water if
it's only cream can't hurt to add
another quarter cup
[Music]
oh it's a little bit there so my cream
has cooled i'm gonna put it in my little
bucket oops i spilled a little and then
let it ice over and chill for two hours
then there should be ice cream
oh come on live with your legs it's been
two hours of patiently oh so patiently
waiting
wasn't heavy at all lightweight look at
that this is like titanic frozen
oh
ho ho
[Music]
just have to carefully unwrap this
[Music]
it would appear that outer edge has
melted frozen but my inside is
completely liquid let's see if it's
fully not in the middle
it's all the way to the bottom the
middle has not gotten frozen so i'm
gonna re-wrap it and just let it chill
for a little bit longer so everything
can freeze this one has been icing over
for several more hours the vessel i use
is probably too narrow and too tall
therefore takes longer for the ice to
penetrate all the way through and set
that middle part so if i'd used
something more flat and shallow it
probably would have frozen within that
two hour period and i can finally see if
it worked let's give this a taste so
this is the mace ice cream
wow
it looks so much like vanilla ice cream
it's almost ready for it to taste like
it and it really does have a very strong
flavor very similar to nutmeg but
something just a little bit different
but i like it it's good it's so funny
they look
basically identical because the
flavorings themselves didn't really add
much color let's give it a taste so it
scoops very easily it's an icier texture
and it's probably because of the water
okay the oh whoa i can't say that this
would hold up to modern standards of
what's considered delicious but it is
definitely
a flavor this is nasty i'm very
surprised that these turned out to
become ice cream they are so similar to
modern ice cream a lot closer than they
thought they would be but the one that
really surprised me was the mace it is
creamy it has a very pleasant flavor
that's very comparable to things that
people are eating nowadays to create
this dessert was definitely a treat of
the time i'm glad people aren't eating
perfume ice cream anymore that was a bad
idea i think it's so cool that this can
just hold its own
right next to what we're eating today i
definitely could do it again
but probably would use an ice cream
machine most definitely we'd use an ice
cream machine
[Music]